[Music]
area hikers are getting ready for a big
event to help raise money for
Make-A-Wish but for one family every
step they take on the hike as a reminder
of how One Wish can be life-changing for
children who are trying to live life to
the fullest Victoria Saha has our story
[Applause]
the Jolly family loved to hike
and their 14 year old son Colin is
following in their footsteps except he's
following in an off-road wheelchair
really is inspiring watching Colin you
know with all the challenges that he
said to deal with just be so happy and
happy and positive Colin was born with a
rare disorder leaving him non-verbal
hour by hour make sure he's taken care
of and then we take care of ourselves
his parents Daniel and Carrie are doing
their best to give him a normal life by
exploring the outdoors
he loves it you just you see it in his
face he's looking around he's engaged
and it just it gets him out there with
everybody and he's just happy but
getting to hike as a family wasn't the
easiest as they would take turns caring
Colin and he was starting to get too big
to for me to carry on my shoulders but
last August one of Colin's doctors
nominated him for Make-A-Wish we were
planning on uh getting an off-road
wheelchair
um we started to do a bunch of research
a wheelchair that would have cost the
family five thousand dollars but make a
wish made the Jolly's wish come true
since then Colin gets to go on every
hike and Adventure from the trails of
Nevada all the way to the lakes of
Wisconsin now the family is giving back
by taking part in a 26.2 mile hike in
February all part of the trailblaze
challenge for Make-A-Wish raising as
much money as possible for these kids to
make as many kids life-changing wishes
come true is what it's really all about
so another family can know that being
physically limited doesn't have to stop
you from climbing your way through life
thank you good job buddy Victoria saw
him eight news now
Make-a-Wish runs on donations so if
you'd like to donate or take part in the
trailblaze hike that's coming up in
February we'll have that information on
our website 8newsnow.com